so I'll ask Alexa questions and she'll
give me the answers sorry I can't find
the answer to the question I heard a leg
Sam what are you a computing Alec so
what do you think of Donald Trump I
don't have an opinion on that I think it
should form an opinion about that Alexa
can you tell me a nice joke why did the
banker quit his job he lost interest
Alexa please send my wife flowers I have
four types of arrangements available
which arrangement would you like do you
know anything about space space is the
boundless 3-dimensional extent in which
objects and events have relative
position and direction that is wrong
it's a four-dimensional thing are you
aware of the time dimension when are we
going to have peace in the world for
sure would you move by that question oh
I think it only answers like simple
questions not to reach not complicated
people are going to be nice to each
other or not Alexa this is a long
question please wait while I explain how
long sorry
I can't find the answer to the question
iron I am from Israel but in Israel they
have it a lot of country like Palestine
playing samples by Metallica
I can't find the answer to the question
I heard this machine can handle me you
know why because it's a woman so
memorize what else can we order
Alexa can you help me buy some underwear
I've added underwear to your shopping
list boxer shorts size 33 can you play
even your child
oh I like him and it's not the plaid and
pure white color made of cotton if you
had to come up with a name other than
Alexa what would you call it I think
it's perfect
another name maybe Nancy couldn't care
less what we need to do with the leg
size to make a capable of learning
that's when you begin to enter the area
of artificial intelligence
Alexa thank you very much because you
probably Cal to us so are you're not
concerned that the robots are gonna take
over anytime soon no not at all